ethan southern california you're on the
bench bureau show before ethan
hey how's it going so i have a few
friends that i've grown up with and
they're on the left
and my question is um when having
conversations and i use statistics that
i hear from your show
they just say that's not true you know
that where'd you find that where'd you
hear that
if they're willing to have a
conversation with me where's the best
place to
get statistics on the spot and where do
you get your statistics so i generally
get my statistics frankly from like
mainstream media publications from
peer-reviewed studies from the from the
government itself uh
there's all sorts of sources where i get
my statistics usually on the show when i
cite a statistic i explain where it came
from
so whenever i talk about the number of
unarmed black men shot in america every
year
i cite the washington post there's a
full-on washington post database and you
can go and you can check it
if you're talking about studies on
disproportionate police shootings for
example roland fryer has done a good
work on this
he's one of several studies on this
particular issue if you're talking
about income inequality there are a wide
variety of sources ranging from abigail
and stephen thurnstrom
at the brookings institute to members of
the heritage foundation to coleman
hughes who've done
investigations into wealth and income
inequality i try to cite sources because
i know that people want the sources
um but you know if you ever are in
search of a particular source i'm citing
feel free to email me my
email address for everyone is be shapiro
at dailywire.com
and i'm more than happy to give you the
sources on on what i discuss i try not
to
speak out of my tokas so to speak and uh
and when i cite a stat
i typically use a source that is fairly
well accepted
cool so if you're having a conversation
it's probably best to come prepared with
some good sources
um and statistics on conversations you
think you might be having with that
person
yeah generally that's right i mean i i
will say that
i think it's very often done in bad
faith when people are like so what
what's your source
on that and you've like if it's a friend
typically if you say like
it's a source i know it's real i just
can't remember it right now for the sake
of the conversation they should assume
that you're not lying
but i understand like i do this all the
time in conversations i've been doing it
since college
where i'll set a stat and somebody will
say where is that from and i try to
you know keep in my head where where all
the stats are from if not then thank god
you have a cell phone you can pull it up
and uh and generally that stuff is
pretty easily available
yeah awesome well hey i really
appreciate that and um i enjoy watching
your show
i watch pretty much 80 of your shows
well that's pretty good i appreciate it
let's get that up to 100 percent ethan
really appreciate
the call fred in detroit you're on the
bench pre-order i'll go for it fred
oh yeah uh first off big fan a little
nervous thank you um
i was wondering i saw on the
dailywire.com you had a
couple references or links um talking
about ufos
um i've seen one in i know we're short
on time i could tell you about it if
you'd like but i was wondering what your
take was the um
i mean do you think their vehicles that
were made by the chinese or russians or
do you think there's some
i don't know life out there i mean all
ufos are right i mean
it literally stands for unidentified
flying objects so i have no idea i mean
it could theoretically be some sort of
machinery that we are not tracking it
could be drones it could be it could be
you know private aircraft it could be a
bunch of different things i really don't
have a clue
as far as the idea that it's aliens um
you know i i am very skeptical of the
idea that alien life forms have reached
earth it feels to me like if they had
and they had the technology to reach
earth from presumably light years away
then they would also have made
themselves quite known because of their
superior technological
abilities it would take quite a while to
get from any place that is inhabited to
to earth so i find it really hard to
believe that aliens are sort of flying
around
but doing nothing like just apparently
doing nothing all day long in the
across the world so uh i'm happy to hear
your ufo story though as long as it
doesn't involve any sort of um
anal probe so go go for it fred what
happened to you yeah
thankfully no but um yeah it was a 1998
um southeast michigan there's a city
called brazil
and um there's a detroit river that runs
right by on the east side
and there's a the river runs between
brazil and
canada so anyway um anyway 1998 i had a
girlfriend she paged me
and we're going to meet on this little
rocky beach at 10 o'clock at night
like play slap and tickle or whatever
you know so like i show up at 9 30
i'm there early i get out i sit on the
hood of my car i'm looking at the stars
and one star i thought it was a star it
was just freakishly bright
and i don't know how many miles i can
see from left to right uh personal
vision
but this thing i mean it i can't even
describe how fast it was
from the left or the entire sky it was
just an
instant the only reason why i could see
it because of the bright
just a bright orb and it left like a
just some kind of trail
anyway it does a perfect 90 degree turn
without hooking or slowing down
which is oh it's so hard to describe but
it was coming to frequent
instant stops i mean it moving at full
speed instant stops
it danced around like that for a few
more seconds until finally it stopped in
front of me
and it's still probably several hundred
yards out and i can kind of make it
in this ball of light i can kind of make
out like a
your typical kind of metallic dome shape
you know structure underneath and it
started to slowly ascend
and as it's getting higher and higher
it's getting faster and faster and
finally it just
in a series of strange flashes of light
it just vanished and
it was almost like a movie i could see
like a strange kind of distortion around
it and
didn't make a sound and ever since then
it just bothered me i've been a
you know a major christian my whole life
so i've been trying to you know make
sense with it physically and yeah i'm
pretty sure it wasn't jesus but i i i
really have no idea
i have no idea i wish i wish i had an
answer for you
on on that one but i have enjoyed this
episode of george nuri
late night radio thanks for the thanks
for the story fred
and and hang in there maybe the aliens
will come and take us with them i mean
frankly it seems like that may be the
solution for the country at this point
it's just to get the hell
off the planet michael in indiana you're
on the bench for go for it michael
hey love listening to your show um i
believe that
over the next few months um there could
be a major shift
in um what i know as a america today
uh something um countries i love to grow
up in
i'm currently raising a family and i've
really started to kick off my career
um now me and um a lot of my
um family um and i believe many others
feel like they're being forced to stay
silent uh
during this um
increasing movement that we're seeing in
some of the larger cities across the u.s
in fear of losing our jobs or careers
we've
this pops up on social media quite
frequently examples of this
so i was curious how do you suggest
we start showing our support against
this
growing movement that many of us are
seeing
in the larger cities across the united
states well it actually starts with
people in power saying no
so if you're a powerful person if you're
a person who doesn't have to be
canceled then refusing to be canceled is
the is the number one thing if somebody
comes to you and they say we demand your
apology for xyz you should just say no
and tucker carlson i disagree with him
on a lot of stuff here he is exactly
right and he's really good at this
people come for his head pretty
routinely and he'll just say no you know
not happening
it's very important that people at the
top of sort of the of the heap
be able to say no because what cancel
culture really is about is intimidating
everybody else it's saying to tucker
okay or or me we're going to come after
your advertisers and if you refuse to
acquiesce
in this if you don't cave to us in our
opinions then
we're going to go after then we're going
to go after you and ruin you and if you
cave to us
then we're just gonna go after people
lower down who have a lot more to lose
so it's it's really important that
people kind of top line defend against
this
if you are you know kind of low on the
food chain a particular company
it's very difficult because you really
are taking your own career into your
hands by saying things that are true
and this is why if canceled culture
continues this way what you're going to
end up with
is a series of companies that are for
the woke and then a series of companies
for everybody else
because basically the woke culture is
trying to make at least half the
population unemployable
just by dint of the viewpoint they hold
about america right now and it's really
dangerous i mean i talked about this a
little bit earlier on the show
is is what majorly sports is attempting
to do right now what professional sports
is attempting to do by cramming down a
particular message
is the idea that if you refuse to accept
the message that america's systemically
racist you are yourself a racist and bad
and you can be canceled just on the
basis of not agreeing that america's a
horrible place
that's really dangerous stuff corporate
america is doing this more and more
the only way to fight back against that
eventually might be for people to stop
patronizing these
businesses which i would not prefer or
for people to start alternative
businesses or for these corporations to
learn that they really should not be
involved in these sorts of issues
because it has nothing to do with the
business that they are in michael
okay i mean i wish i had an answer
better than that i wish i had an answer
that says
stand up and say what you believe and
there won't be consequences but that
obviously isn't true
i mean i think there are people like me
out there who will stand up and fight
with you that if you get fired for
saying something true
then i'll find a way to support you but
i think that the the
basic notion that we can do that for you
know tens of millions of people who feel
under threat
it's very difficult now should there be
flash points absolutely do you want to
be one of those
those flash points that that is your
choice right now i'm not gonna
recommend to anybody they put their
career at risk because i'm not the one
who has to put
food on their kid's table right i think
that if you want to stand up and fight
and then you want people like me to
resonate to to what you're saying
then i'm happy to do it i think it's
really important that people again in
positions of
power with loudspeaker do that and we
try to do that a lot over at daily wire
but i can't recommend that everybody
take on that risk because that's a
personal decision that everybody has to
make individually
okay well michael appreciate the call
hang in there dude
chris in the bay area you're on the
bench bureau show how's it going chris
hi ben how's it going oh it's going
pretty well how's it going from the
lands of needles in open poop
well i'm glad i haven't accepted it yet
that's very very um
heartening for me um i actually have a
reading question for you
i know you read a lot of books some of
them at the same time i'm trying to do
that myself
and i'm wondering if you have any tips
on how to get started and doing that
so the the best way that i've found to
read is i have to kind of switch off
because
if my attention span starts to wane uh
then i tend to read more slowly and
i will lose energy in one book and then
i'll switch to the other book very often
happens
so i usually have one fun book and one
serious book that i'm reading at the
same time
so i'll read some fiction and at the
same time i'm reading fiction i'm
reading the biography of stalin or
something
and that's a nice way of sort of giving
my brain a break while still
bringing in a lot of information it
doesn't have to be you know fiction it
can also be a sports book or it can be
something that you find a little bit
lighter or more fun uh
that's that's how i take in information
as far as how to read faster typically
speaking
there are certain structures to
non-fiction books in particular that you
get to know
introductions are important conclusions
are important first three paragraphs of
a chapter are important last three
chapters of a paragraph are important
very often you'll find i won't say this
about my own books because i think my
books are kind of philosophy and content
heavy but there are a lot of books
where they just sort of repeat the same
point over and over and over and they
just footnote it a lot
and unless you intend on memorizing some
of those data points which very often is
useful
what you really want to know is where in
the book that information is
you don't want to necessarily read
through all that information right now
so the way i tend to treat some
nonfiction books is as sort of reference
manual so i know where in the book for
example
this person is going to talk about
criminal statistics and i footnote it
you know
the way i like to read non-fiction books
is i i don't like writing in books
because
i know i have this bizarre almost
religious objection to
defacing books even though it really
isn't doing it um
and so what i what i found is really
good is you buy those um
those colored tabs the sticky tabs and i
use that to highlight sections of the
book because those are always removable
later
if anybody else wants to read the book
and it doesn't obstruct their ability to
read the book
so my books are covered in tabs my copy
of to tokville democracy in america i
went through like three packages of
tabbed
um but i think that's a good way to kind
of footnote it and come back to it which
is really the best part
of of reading is now you know where
everything is and that's the most
important when it comes to non-fiction
that's the most important
yeah awesome thank you very much i
appreciate that you bet thanks chris